[Applaudissements]
alors mettez vous la laisse en rigoler
je sais pas qui me ressemblent vous
n'êtes dégueulasse gilles verdez
attention c'est parti qui commence ses
galons bah oui allez les gars on sépare
capella comme ça
déjà qu'ils bassin
[Musique]
et si tu craques usineur j'ai donné
vacances en manque
je suis ko debout
si tu crois que j'ai eu tort at on
respire respire respire en plus le
souffle d'art qui me pousse en avant
c'est comme si j'avais pris la mer
là qu'on voit que je fais comme si je
quittais la
si je quittais la deux j'ai trouvé mon
et toi aussi
[Musique]
je les ai suivis 1
je
cytos un répit après les dangers
tu crois que je j'espère que non
j'écoute ouvres ton corps
au vent de la nuit ferment les yeux
j'ai glissé sous le vent
tout glisse et d'indicés
j'aimerais bien que tu es là
j'ai trop
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]